hey guys i'm philip molina this is Erik
Bosse hey guys and this is a breakdown
of that new trailer for Doctor Strange
it's one of the million things that came
out of Comic Con that we're trying to
cover as best we can so we're gonna
point out some of the things that you
might not have noticed I know some
things out no one noticed and just some
stuff from that new preview comic I
don't know if you guys saw that that
came out a couple weeks ago but why
don't we just get right into it yeah
let's get started
Doctor Strange you think you know how
the world works so this opening section
gives us another introduction to dr.
Stephen strange and just like that first
teaser that came out a few months ago
the movie looks like it's gonna stick to
that Marvel or Jane of the character
he's this arrogant but amazing surgeon
he clearly also is real good with his
hands if you know what I mean and by
that I mean playing the piano that we're
currently hearing and he's also really
super freakin rich and then as we see it
all comes crumbling down for him and an
accident and then the voice that we hear
think you know how the world works yes
this is the ancient one played by Tilda
Swinton we'll talk more about who the
ancient one is in just a second but
right now she's calling out strange as
this arrogant know-it-all that we know
who he is and of course he's played by
Benedict Cumberbatch who is perfect
casting choice for Doctor Strange and
seen a play arrogant know-it-alls in the
past with Sherlock and as con from the
Star Trek sequel and then as Smaug the
dragon from the Hobbit movie let's keep
going what if I told you the reality you
know is one of many
this doesn't make any sense
not everything does not everything has
to and then we see this aftermath and
it's not the worst way to wake up to
seeing Rachel McAdams as the night nurse
version that had not resided option from
the Netflix shows this is yeah Rachel
McAdams total hottie but also she's
Cristina Palmer here and in the comics
night nurse is associated with dr.
strange she's also kind of associated
with a bunch of superheroes but it seems
that they're gonna focus her on just him
and look at his freakin hands destroyed
like miserably breaking like they got
pins in them stuff clearly this is a guy
who just went from the highest high to
the lowest low and he's gonna need a way
to cure his hands yeah and just like he
does in the comics that his journey to
heal his hands takes them to the Far
East specifically Tibet in China you see
that he has this beard this is
definitely a long time has passed here
and that journey to Tibet introduces him
to the ancient one who we mentioned
before the ancient one to dr. strange is
kind of this mentor figure like Yoda or
Morpheus to forget into matrix parallels
the ancient one was born 500 years ago
and discovered magic at a very young age
not something ancient one ages very
slowly so he's super old but doesn't
really look that old and his job is to
protect the world and other dimensions
through the years from dark magic forces
yeah and to clarify the ancient one is a
title that one adopts now it wasn't
always that exact thing but they fix the
whole whitewashing things I say that
it's a title but I'm buying going with
that that's just a title that is now on
tilda swinton
yes yeah so we've seen the background of
these sots Chua tell as you for who is
amazing and everything he's in he plays
Baron Mordo who there's a long history
there in the comics we're gonna get back
to that soon actually but then we see
Stephen pushed through this kind of
glass crystal barrier that's showing a
different sort of reality what's kind of
cool is that they lifted this from that
scene an ant-man where he kind of goes
into the quantum small space showing
what it's like to cross into almost
another dimension you can see more of
this actually in the title sequence with
the new version of the Marvel Studios
title but they like Kaleidoscope the
comics instead of showing them normal
through the mystic arts we harness
energy and shape reality
we travel great distances in an instant
so in this next section we see some of
the amazing visuals of this movie these
inception style effects as we see the
ancient one reshaping this London city
block and we know it's London because
you can see the crossroads here are
great Scotland Yard and Northumberland
Avenue that's within the City of London
and these trippy visuals are inspired
clearly by Steve Ditko he's the co
creative dr. strangeness artwork is
amazing it's great to see them use this
in the movie and also we see some of
these complex impossible architecture
that like Inception was clearly inspired
on the artwork of MC Escher and actually
yet Doctor Strange comics in general
they're known for these crazy artistic
visuals so they didn't only change the
visual layout of comic books in general
for Marvel they're doing that for the
movies now - not just for the look of
where they are but potentially the way
that Marvel wants to portray other
dimensions and realities and also real
quick we see why Doctor Strange is such
a cool game changer to bring into the
MCU is that he uses magic and mystical
arts that's something we've seen really
any other Marvel movie character used
before we've seen different parts of the
cosmos and different kinds of science
fiction but not magic so it's cool to
see that during the Marvel Universe let
me hop over through a freaking portal to
the Himalayas I think and what's really
interesting here is that looks like a
lot of the trainee is gonna go down in
these mountains of Tibet or whatever
that's so similar to what happened with
Bruce Wayne and Batman Begins where he
goes to actually the same part of the
world to go train with Ra's al Ghul just
another one of these kind of Christopher
Nolan connections it's similar to their
like prism angular images here the
obviously they're like upside down city
bending visuals and inception and yeah
Batman Begins his training sequence but
honestly who cares because I loved Nolan
movie so it's great let's move on so I
get from here to there
how did you become a doctor studying
practice
so here we see the starred hands of dr.
Stephen strange as these opening this
book and what book is this pretty sure
that this is the book of vishanti
and the Doctor Strange comics the book
of vishanti contains all the positive
spells and the counter spells of the
mystical arts that he's learning it's a
spell book right away you can tell that
they're like stinking pretty close to
the visuals of the comics with the way
that he like harnesses the magical
energy and goes over his arm and whatnot
if you look closely though as that prism
that shows up starts to go away it looks
like some people or some guards or
something might be like chasing after
I'm like hey you this oh you're not
supposed to be touching our book a spell
so this is probably one of these things
where like a person that's like too
smart for their own good is just like
trying to get ahead of their training
and they find themselves in a bad
situation but also adventure let's keep
going there's a strength to him that is
are you ready
the devil which pass who travel
downstream stronger men than you have
but the way
I have death
and pain
okay so now we see two hotel as Baron
Mordo like I talked about earlier and
he's supposed to be a fellow student but
here it kind of looks like he's you know
owning the place to kind of like you
know you have a Taekwondo master and
then the like slightly younger
better-looking version of him that like
it's kind of in charge of the day-to-day
that seems like what more does doing
here he's kind of a disciple of the
ancient wine and in the comics here's a
big deal it's pretty well known so I
wouldn't call this a spoiler but if
you're like no nothing at all I don't
know anything then jump to this time but
Baron Mordo I'm speaking slowly on
purpose is eventually going to turn
against Doctor Strange it's just based
on this trailer doesn't seem like it
happens in this movie again I'm gonna
say it's really well known in the comics
he's one of the villains but pretty
interesting if this ends up having not
only an arc for Benedict Cumberbatch's
Stephen strange but also for Baron Mordo
turning from the light side to the dark
and then we see Doctor Strange looking
at his famous cloak of levitation and
it's in this case like it's a hundis
play at Comic Con or something this is
the cloak that allows him to fly he and
kind of direct it like it's a magic
carpet from Aladdin all this looks like
it's in the sanctum sanctorum that's
Doctor Strange his home mansion in the
comics it magically expands on the
inside it's basically his face of
operations where he stores all of his
magical artifacts yeah I'll say it
doesn't seem like immediately at this
moment he like owns this place
maybe it'll be bequeathed to him by the
end of the movie don't laugh it's a
funny word uh and then actually in the
comics a lot of the defenders end up
working out of that place at times I
feel like that's not gonna happen
because they don't love to cross the TV
shows and movies over and then of course
we get this obligatory MCU hero
shirtless shot as Doctor Strange is
shaving his facial hair into an
interesting goatee like another famous
marble arrogant who had a severe
life-threatening injury and then had to
find his soul through the end of the
film and powers then we see these three
amazing windows that could just be like
three different HD screens showing
different environments but they're
probably portals themselves to a forest
ocean and mountains and when he opens
that window and we see him looking over
the ocean that's probably our best shot
of the eye of agamotto hanging it right
over his chest so the eye of agamotto is
a big deal this whole prequel comic that
they put out it's all about taking that
away from someone who's not worthy of it
and giving it to someone who is
worthy they don't finish it there but
obviously he's the one that ends up with
it it's the most powerful object that
dr. strange really has right now it's
one of these eyes that was created by
this vishanti guy his nametag Emoto
obviously it can give you telepathic
powers it can rewind and manipulate
reality and create doorways also through
time and space so there's a moment later
that comes up that I think is gonna
legitimate one claim that a lot of
people are making that it could be one
of the sought-after Infinity stones I'll
bring it up when we get to it but yeah
I'm starting to feel like this could be
the time stone that Thanos is
desperately after and when they say some
stronger man than you the way they're
clearly referring to this guy this is
Mads Mikkelsen scare achter we were
wondering what villain he would be
playing some thought it would be
Dormammu that Stephen strange is
recurring major villain from the comics
let the prequel comic that we were
talking about said that this guy is
going to be we think his name is case
Silius sorry if I'm not saying that
right he's a good guy in the prequel
comic that we saw but it's hinted that
he's gonna turn bad and in earlier
Doctor Strange comics Casilla is a
slightly more obscure villain he's
actually discipled Baron Mordo
after more dough turns bad he uses the
powers of Dormammu through kuselias to
attack Doctor Strange out of the way
whatever it is he's an amazing actor and
I love when this guy plays a bad guy and
the character looks great except I can't
look at his eyes it creeps me out so
much the like area around it is like
blood or guts or muscle or pizza face I
hate it anyway they're clearly having
some major battle in some Asian City and
it's totally wrecked so there probably
is gonna be an intense battle sequence
there I check out that window behind him
but looks like the eye of agamotto
symbol that they use in the sanctum so
based on that and a few other shots that
we're gonna see in a bit I feel like
he's actually gonna attack the sanctum
itself I think the sanctum ironically
because of the what that word means is
not a safe place for him to go to but
more on that later and before we move on
we get the shot of the night nurse it
looks like she's trying to revive Steven
strange but it's after he's already
become a sorcerer he's wearing his new
clothes so I feel like some stuffs gonna
be going down in New York also sparks
are flying because they love each other
I checked on this wall I can't do this
there is no other way
so this section here is one of my
favorites actually it's showing that
light and that only is the world you
know at risk once again New York streets
are actually like bending as this portal
opens if you look closely you can see
the Steven strange and mortar are
running towards that as mads mikkelsen
scare achter is chasing them right now
they're actually running toward the
Empire State Building I think there's
gonna be a huge chase sequence in New
York but also I actually have feelings
can take place all around the world
maybe at the same time which is an
amazing idea and totally takes advantage
of what happens when you have a bunch of
people that can use all kinds of magic
in a fight I've got that's one of these
things that's just gonna make this movie
stand apart then we see Doctor Strange
creating this cool cat's cradle thing
with magic beams between his hands that
could be the crimson bands of cyttorak
from the comics just not crimson not
crimson in golden bands maybe even if
it's not it could be him creating this
fire whip thing and I'm wondering if
that's part of his yellow sash if you
read the comics you know that his sash
can actually extend to ten times its
normal length and he kind of uses it to
fight and lasso people or it could just
be him using magic to create this
awesome whip thing that he used to take
people down and if you look around right
now I mean magic right there this is
that moment I was talking about that it
feels like the sanctum might be under
attack at some point and then we cut to
a different fight and it's maybe of
fight in a different location with that
block of an Asian city but notice here
watch them fighting they're fighting
totally normally but everything around
on that destruction it's going in
Reverse the wreckage is getting
unwrapped so this is what makes me think
we might have the time gem on our hands
or time stone and the marble movies also
they might not even be fighting in that
same location because if you look at
their feet like the ground around them
it kind of looks like it's not the road
so this could be one of these like
trippy things where they're fighting in
some sort of like face that is traveling
through dimensions and spaces all around
the world again that'd be so cool you
guys better do that in the movie because
I've hyped it up so much now let's keep
going
in full-time
looking for you here we're seeing more
this reality bending New York chase
sequence and we're seeing more cool
angles of just a skyline like in
Inception folding on top of itself
forming in this shot a doughnut hole in
the middle of the city if you look
closely you can see Avengers tower right
in the middle there also how nice of the
ancient one to say she's been looking
for this guy
through time that means that he could be
the one the neo of the Marvel Universe
but really he's stepping up into his
role that he eventually gets in the
comics anyway of sorcerer supreme the
primary defender of Earth from dark
magic Baron Mordo kind of feels like he
should get the job so I wouldn't be
surprised that plays a role on what
flips into the dark side and also I'll
just say real quick strangest face here
this badass cape whip shot is bloodied
so I feel like maybe that's the cap of
the attack on the sanctum earlier now
he's like you know what I'm taking this
cape I'm gonna go through this comic-con
case and take it for myself and then he
goes to save the world but let's wrap
this thing up
but what's this my mantra it's the Wi-Fi
password we're not savages okay so this
whole Wi-Fi joke with the word Shambhala
I think that's a reference to the Doctor
Strange graphic novel into Shambhala
he's definitely a reference I think
finally right no I don't know limb what
about that's when Doctor Strange visits
the home of the ancient one in the
Himalayas he finds this ancient artifact
that the intro one left for him and it
ends up being a communication device
with the Lords of Shambhala they're from
a higher reality that give dr. strange
an opportunity to help humanity reach
another golden age so I feel like it
being the Wi-Fi password or more to say
hey we're not savages they saying that
Shambhala is how humans access the
Internet and it's their version of the
higher form of reality okay but the
final shot uh is that's pretty intense
dr. Strange's taking obviously some sort
of massive attack and he's doing that
thing where he's like standing up
against it and he's slowly starting to
rise but those shield kind of shapes
he's got one behind it but also I think
is one in front of him that could be a
magical shield that obviously he's just
made right in that moment it could also
be though a physical embodiment of the
invisible shield of everlasting and
shame and essentially it's a really long
fancy way to say when you magical you
got like a layer of shields like cling
wrap but all over you um that could be
the Marvel movies interpretation to that
where he's just got like a little shield
ticking pop up in magical forms but
that's it that's the entirety of this
trailer I'm super hyped for this movie
I'm a huge magic Cumberbatch fan that's
I think ninety-nine thousand percent why
I'm gonna see this movie but also I mean
there's a bunch of great actors in it
I'm wondering what's your favorite thing
to look forward to about this movie that
just inclusion of magic is it just the
Cumberbatch cuz it's probably that oh
what's your favorite thing for me it's
gonna be all the visual effects I love
how this movie looks I'm sorry if
they're gonna adapt to Doctor Strange
comic into a movie that they wouldn't
get the visuals just right but this is
exactly how I'd want this movie to look
it looks amazing
plus you love goatees can't get enough
all right so I thank you so much for
watching if you want to support us in
doing these breakdowns and tackling way
more topics like we have been lately
actually then hit us up on patreon
that's making a huge difference it's
letting us get
is a faster edited faster shot faster
more topics we're actually getting a
tiny little office space somewhere look
at us so if you want to be one of the
people that's helping us out that weighs
patreon.com splashed new rock stars if
you want to just help us out other ways
you can share this video and share all
of our videos and subscribe to this
channel if you want to hit me up or just
simple little chatter it's 200 comm
slash fimo you can hit me up on Twitter
at EA boss and you can also follow new
rockstars on Twitter at new rockstars
for information about when our videos
are gonna be coming out that's where
that information goes when the videos
are coming out it's at new rock stars
that said I think we're good to go right
alright thanks guys bye bye